super excited for a another episode of
coffee and commerce i'm here with my far
more handsome partner in crime zubin
uh and we have a pretty epic uh guest
with us this week a gentleman that i've
admired from far so i'm excited that i
get to jam with him a little bit here
admire because i think it comes from a
like a good place i'll let him get into
it
and i'm just big shout out to everybody
who's watching right now i'm gonna go
into
manning social here a little bit to
build up some hype and get everybody
listening because i think we're gonna
have a remarkable
show so jason uh first of all thank you
so much for being on the show
thank you for having me and uh zubin why
don't you uh create the context for the
audience a little bit about jason and
we'll let him talk a little bit about it
then we'll get into the q a and i will
start to uh
play my color commentary uh that i like
to do in these episodes
let's do it i love it um yeah jason
great to have you on
uh just for the audience to give you
some context
the stuff that we talk about often has
to do with one aspect of e-commerce or
another but what we're really focused on
is e-com
holistically direct consumer
holistically and how to build companies
how to build brands
and i think uh jason is really a special
individual
as it comes to that because he's gone
and done
so much so i'll let jason tell you about
his past his story but he's
it's been around starting a hedge fund
building that
going through some things personally
that i'd love for you to talk about
jason
and then where he is now in terms of
founding um and being the ceo of humanco
just a fascinating story and uh jason
why don't you tell us the story and
we'll jump
in sure um so
i uh i started in the hedge fund
business in 1998
um actually the quantitative analyst and
i was a quant for my first
uh five years uh then i morphed more
into a fundamental uh
portfolio manager and investor
which i then did up until
the end of 18 early 19.
i worked at at three firms where i had
some terrific mentors
uh in public investing most of my focus
in public investing was
on uh long short equity uh with a
quantity
backbone but um you know i think
as uh someone has a child
it's too much holiday life in here all
the nieces and yeah over there
um and uh
but but how i got uh introduced or drawn
into
in into consumer products really is a
more of a personal story
um when i when i started uh
in the hedge fund world about a year and
a half in um
i was you know working 16 18 hours a day
doing what kind of young people in in
new york city tend to do
and i got very sick um i was ultimately
diagnosed at the age of 23
with a variety of autoimmune diseases uh
one of which they told me i was going
blind um and that i would be blind by
the age of 30.
on that front yeah you know because this
actually could be the biggest impact
we have in this episode and this is kind
of what the reference for everybody's
watching kind of what i said in my
admiration because i
i um i really admire taking adversity
and
understanding it and then building on
top of it and from at least from afar
and i don't have every tea and i crossed
on you like none of us do about each
other but
i really appreciate where you're about
to take this but before especially
in in case i bail before this time runs
out
you having those issues yeah
for my own knowledge to be frank you
know my brother has crohn's disease
and my brother left vaynermedia you know
kind of abruptly
for similar reasons which was like but
he wasn't actually working like
hedge fund land he just it was the
stress
of doing something he didn't like enough
that kind of made him go there
yep um but the extreme
of like you at that young of an age
having those things happen
for my own education because because
because i
worked a lot of hours to in my youth and
things that nature
was that dna that was inevitable in
any way was that dna that was sitting
there inside
of you that got triggered by some of
this how much of that was
mental from the standpoint of um
less about the actual physical
exhaustion but you yourself
were in a place in your life at that
time where you were beating yourself up
so much it was an
unhealthy ambition yeah let me break
that down because
one thing i fear like finding the
juxtaposition between
you know i stood ten years ago i used to
use the word hustle
now i don't because it's been
manipulated into a world that does
have a negative connotation around it
being mental burnout so now i just use
work ethic but i still believe in it and
what i fear
is not what i fear what i'm trying to
figure out all the time is how do we
find the right balance between
hey work ethic is a requirement to have
success because otherwise you get into
delusion and entitlement and the secret
and all sorts of
other bad stuff and burning out to like
exhaustion
and like mental you know upsetness
is completely unacceptable but i but i
always try to figure out two things one
how much was that in you from a chemical
standpoint
and how much were you unhealthy with
your ambition
because you lacked the patience and you
wanted the wall street things that came
along with it like
who were you at that point as a man
because i think what i've noticed is a
lot of people
are getting confused at a young age of
like should i work
a lot should i work a little like and
and so i think and i appreciate your
energy right now because i think the
clarity underneath there
really really matters because it can
really help someone
because someone could be comfortable
with work ethic because they're happy
and they don't need a mercedes
or it reverts you see where i'm going
brother totally totally it's a great
question
thank you and um you know i
uh it's a combination to answer the
question um you know i've had my dna
sequence a few times now
uh in the last four or five years
they've actually
it's gotten to a place where they can
give you sort of some reliable feedback
on some of your
predispositions and some of the things
that you
uh you might be prone to um
you know i'm a big believer in
epigenetics which is this concept of
it's a combination of nature and nurture
in terms of what actually manifests
um you know i think for me what was
really difficult was
you know i was a chronic underachiever
up until
like mid high school and and
just you think real quick do you think
that that was in hindsight
a huge advantage in your life yeah i
think the transition from going from
huge underachiever to overachiever in
college
was something that was pretty remarkable
for me are you talking in the macro or
are you talking academically
i'm talking kind of broad i mean all of
it because
i you know i was one of those kids and
most people who know me today who didn't
know me as a child
don't believe any of this but anyone who
grew up with me will confirm this so
um i was one of those kids who never did
his homework
played or played a lot with video games
weapons explosives chemistry kits
um i was that kid that a lot of parents
told
their kids that they couldn't play with
because i was a bad influence
um and you know by the way on the record
i had that too
i wasn't it's explosive or disruptive
and i don't know if you were
disrespectful any of those other
variables
i was just such an atrocious student
that parents were scared their kids
would get bad grades
yeah i you know it's funny because i
didn't most most
aspects of school i didn't like um and
i've always had 80d
and i didn't really know how to channel
it but but
a few people sort of noticed um my
precociousness in a few areas that i did
like
um and then i had a couple teachers in
high school
who just took me under their wing and
they and they really taught me how to
sort of get my [ __ ] together
and then i miraculously got into penn um
which today i you know explained that
like
you know because i went to mall out of
college with my [ __ ] school so
like the pen thing is confusing did you
crush
junior and senior year nsats and it was
just momentum
was it like a great uncle like built a
german pen
like what what happened there yeah i
think it was a combo of a bunch of
things
i was very well-rounded i was the
captain of my tennis team i was sort of
a quasi-athletic
by my business partner in the vayner x
world ryan harwood who runs our
publishing side
and robin you know he got he went to
penn
and uh and i fully know it's because of
tennis
yeah and you know i played four years of
college squash when i got there and
and uh but what years were you there
i was 90 i graduated in 1998.
okay so you're my age so you're older
than you don't know ryan okay keep going
um and uh but what happened was
i was into life hacking and self-hacking
before it was like a phrase
and i you know i started teaching myself
how to become really efficient in
college
because i had to balance my athletic
schedule with my academic schedule
and i started doing really well early
and i was able to sort of recreate my
identity
from being this underachiever in high
school to now being this sort of like
achiever um and then what happened was
i i was raised you know in a way that
was always about over achievement even
though i didn't really do it
and i started to see that when i applied
myself in college the results were
coming
and i i effectively created this
positive feedback loop
that ultimately led to what you know my
various psychiatrists called a god
complex
where i ultimately believe the harder i
worked
the better my results would be at the
expense of everything else in my life
and were you were you happy were you a
happy person
i think initially i was happy but then
what happened was
and one other thing what about outside
affirmation in the form of human
judgment
did people's opinions have
weight with you yeah definitely you know
i was a second child i definitely cared
a lot about what people thought of me
um i i think i was motivated at that
time
um you know to succeed financially
um you know i think as a proxy to show
that you
like yeah so as a proxy for sort of
validation and success
um and that's like the thing that i
will forever be passionate about i wish
i i'm i mean you you may know this i
have no idea how much context you have
on me i spent an ungodly amount of
effort
trying to get people to understand the
victory that is
loving your game more than what comes
with it
so you can use it for validation right
like i literally saw a garage sale sign
this morning josh i swear this is real
did good morning america jump in a car
literally did good morning america 15
minutes which is like
like you know like really neat for my
mom and this is that like all that stuff
drive to my parents here for the jewish
holiday which is why i'm gonna bounce a
little
early happy new year to all of you
happy new year brother literally saw a
garage sale sign
and one of the turns i made going in my
parents like kind of area off the
highway
and got more chemical juice hype
of the potential maybe tomorrow morning
i'll wear a mask and go and look through
somebody's trash
then everything that was associated with
good morning america today
process over the and it hit me i thought
of it i was like
man if these [ __ ] people actually
knew that what i just said was
true fully true that the game of waking
up at 6am having a coffee going there
and trying to find a 13 item on ebay for
50 cents
gives me more yeah i've always been that
way like
everything everything interests me and
what happened was gary was
um everything i started applying myself
to
and and learning all these life hacks
kept working
and and i went i went from
you know i don't even think i was top 50
in my high school class
and i graduated number three and in
wharton which is the top school in the
country
and um and all of that was just from
application and i did that at the same
time as as being a walk-on to the squash
team
and ended up being a an all-ivy and
all-american
um and so i developed this loop of like
everything i applied myself to just kept
working
and so when i ended up getting into the
working environment
and i thought oh i can apply the same
kind of approach
to working and i'll make a lot more
money and i'll move up the ladder and
all this stuff
and and within a year and a half i
achieved financial success that i didn't
think i would achieve for a decade
and yet i started getting very sick and
i
started wondering like wow i'm depressed
i look like [ __ ] i feel like [ __ ] i'm
losing
my jason you think you know i stopped
rooting for the yankees and the rangers
when they won
their championships literally colt never
watched another real game
do you think there is any chance that
when you establish jason that kind of
financial success that because you got
there
it trick triggered the momentum of like
[ __ ]
like i'm here this sucks like do you
think like back to process
do you think there was i think what
happened to that was was
and it wasn't just about financial
success i just
you know you can when one of the one of
the myths
of of work hard play hard um is sort of
not taking care of things that you can't
quantify
and so when i got into this mode of
learning how to speed read learning how
to shortcut
sleep you know i basically eliminated
exercise i eliminated my friends
i eliminated things that i thought were
unnecessary to my goals
you became you became infatuated with
these new things that nobody else
understood and you took for granted
tried and true
yeah and i thought i thought i could
will myself to like greatness
and i had a completely misperception of
what greatness was
and i also um excluded all the things
that i think make people healthy
um and so i had a totally warped
perception of being an overachiever
and and i suffered and i later learned
that my physiology and my dna
and i have a couple polymorphisms which
is kind of a euphemism for
you know mutations in in in your dna
i have a couple polymorphisms that make
me prone
to not detoxifying properly which
ultimately drives my autoimmune issues
and ultimately drop
drove my um my degenerative corneal
disease
and i had to sort of go through a lot of
therapy
i had to do a lot of self-discovery
about what i really was trying to do
um and it was all at the age of 23 24.
um when uh and i'm kind of actually
grateful that i got so sick when
i did because i think it ultimately made
me more
of a balanced person i think it
ultimately made me a better person
and it ultimately i think made me more
successful because i think i actually
would have
probably died if i just stayed on that
course
without you know pausing and recognizing
that balance
is an essential element to success
um so yeah so so anyway
along that along those lines um i became
after i cured myself or technically in
remission but
i became fascinated by because my issue
is what i put in my body and on my body
primarily food
beverage things like personal care
lotion shampoos
toothpaste etc and i became an expert
because i had to
on all adulterants that go into products
and
everything that we as people take for
granted
we assume that when we buy stuff that we
put in or on our body we
assume that the people making it have
our best interest in mind
and they generally don't and most of
what modern humans consume
have different levels of toxic toxicity
do you believe that people
think that those companies have their
best interests in mind or do you think
that people don't actually think about
it at
all in the scheme of things the latter
yeah right
like people walking around being like
[ __ ] crafts got my best right to your
boy
but gary what i find remarkable is that
most people that i deal with in finance
and and in private equity and certainly
most people who are listening to this
call right now
they're probably very diligent people
who
you know take a lot of things seriously
in their life they take their job
seriously
but it's amazing to me how most of those
people who are disciplined and diligent
in most aspects of their life will walk
outside
pre-covered of course we'll walk outside
go to a food truck
ask the guy for a sandwich presume that
it's clean
not know if the guy's an ex-convict and
just you know adulterated the sandwich
not know what's in it not
ask any questions and we just presume
that when we're putting things on or in
our body
that like it's fine and it's amazing to
me that we don't have
more paranoia and vigilance we have we
presume
everything we presume we presume there's
macro things going on in society
politically in our country and
everywhere like the
humans great vulnerability has been
historically assumption
yes so i agree with you like you know i
went on your behalf
you know it originally started kind of
philanthropically and just as a mission
and a passion
to look for companies
that cared about people over profits
that actually had a mission
for providing better for you cleaner
stuff
and actually had some evidence behind
what they put in their stuff and without
shortcuts
and my brother-in-law jordan brown my
wife
who's uh his uh sister
uh and i we started a company called
hugh
i have i have the chocolate bar right
here actually
um uh we started a restaurant hold on
hold on this is major
it's a major moment please bring that
back up
so you have a cashew butter one right
yeah this is the cashew butter raspberry
oh i'd [ __ ] that wasn't as fun as it
could have been because i didn't see the
small print
i have like 11 of those in my cabinet
and i'm obsessed with it
and had literally no [ __ ] idea this
is like
the connection point so i'm super
i eat these as a snack while i'm just
hanging out you're about to learn
something about me i'm like
the most detailed and the most aloof in
this like i'm omni
i feel like i'm just like it's i'm a
weird character of like knowing that
much about your macro
and obviously the guys are working with
you at vader cobbs and i swear to god i
have 11 of those
11 of those not here at my parents i
would have grabbed i'm so [ __ ] pissed
that i'm not in my apartment right now
because i would have grabbed them and
showed you
they're [ __ ] amazing thank you here's
another one
i had no idea they were that good for me
yeah we look we the the original genesis
of of hue
was that we felt like people don't eat
like humans anymore
and that a lot of the modern problems
obesity diabetes heart disease stress
um you know there's a lot of correlation
between mood depression
and uh your microbiome and what you're
putting in your body
but the original genesis behind you was
we wanted to have a place where you
could trust everything that was in it
and uh and it just started kind of as a
passion it wasn't really meant
to become what it is um and then the
chocolate and the products
started taking off um and while i was
doing my day job
as a hedge fund portfolio manager and
when we started hugh was like the
perfect wrong timing for me
because we started you the same month
that i launched my own hedge fund it was
like just kind of a
weird coincidence um real quick
i feel like i'm talking to zubin i think
i've completely side railed this thing
because i'm just interested in your
energy
amazing yeah but like we are supposed to
talk a little bit about commerce here
right we're getting there
because i'm reading the comments and one
guy's very upset with me we'll get to
him don't worry about it keep going
all right i gotta leave in two minutes
anyway so everybody's watching i'm sorry
i'm just
enjoying this and the chocolate thing
got me hyped and i love this guy's macro
because i think
to your point jason i think so much of
what i'm blessed for and i'm knocking on
wood
is macro in the same way that you talk
about
what people put in their body i am
flabbergasted by people's inability to
understand you find what you're looking
for in life
yeah like like like perspective is
literally
like the sheer the sadness i see when i
see
cynicism because it's a choice you know
when i like like you know like i
i when i'm what i'm so happy about is
that you and many others
have created enormous momentum over the
last decade around what we're putting in
our bodies
i think i'm ahead on what's going on up
here
i really do i really do i think the
things that people view me as like too
fluffy for
kindness karma you know uh i'm a
motivational speaker even though i build
all these [ __ ] businesses in
everybody's face like
when they try to razz me they don't
understand it's practical
yeah yeah look a lot of a lot of
the genesis behind this and and and this
was the predecessor to what i'm doing
now with with human code but
i felt so i went a decade
trying to find things that i could
safely consume
that didn't aggravate my own conditions
and i lost
trust and faith in most of the products
that were out there
and and when i found healthy products
and it's not just food like i needed to
do this with things like toothpaste and
shampoo and
and when i found healthy products most
of the time you consider
is that the right word that like yeah
yeah this is a very clean label
uh yeah and and at the next step i i
know i'm getting ridiculous but i'm
having fun
like it feels like clean is the the next
step of like people started
understanding how to be
more thoughtful with calories people
start but it feels like clean
is really like what you're talking about
and by the way i've stumbled a little
bit more
hence why i have these [ __ ] things in
my house i've gotten way more clean
and i'm pretty excited about i think
there's some logic to it yeah
look there's a lot of logic to it and
there's a reason why it's it's the
fastest growing segment of food
is because for a lot of people they feel
better
even if they didn't have the conditions
that i have for a lot of people you look
better you sleep better you feel better
you don't have to count calories that's
a complete myth um
except if you're consuming like five six
thousand calories of stuff
um and you know the problem that i
wanted to address as an entrepreneur was
most of the healthy stuff that was out
there
tasted like [ __ ] and i felt like i was
sacrificing
every time i wanted healthy stuff
um and then there was stuff that sort of
masqueraded as healthy
that tasted great but it really wasn't
healthy i mean that's that's the
dominant force today right like people
that got smarter
and you think you're eating a bar that's
good and you're like wait a minute this
is worse than the snickers
or at least equal which by the way me as
the entrepreneur and marketer i'm like
ooh kudos to you guys that like [ __ ]
worked
like like you definitely made me think
you know but the math doesn't play out
right so my brother-in-law and i and my
wife
we just wanted to make epic [ __ ] and we
had very strict guardrails
about what we could use as ingredients
and how we made it
and we we wouldn't release anything that
we didn't think was epic
and it shocks me how many things out
there
are mediocre like to most people and
they still get released
like we you know and i take kind of a
steve jobsian approach to this
where i want stuff that i want to binge
on and i want stuff that i think
is epic and if it's not epic i'm not
going to do it
and on your subjective opinion which is
what's going to lead to some failures
which is really hard yeah correct and
i'm going to go back to something i'm
going to get out of here because kids
are screaming
and i'm ruining this show which is what
goes back to the beginning of mediocrity
in the beginning
your capacity for that is going to be
high
i love this balance between
deep [ __ ] conviction and wild
humility
i've been thinking about this a ton like
like
i literally think that i could be the
greatest of all time
and equally no i mean nothing and i
deploy that in execution a lot and i'm
trying to understand it
and i see it here and i see it in other
things and it's the most obvious thing i
[ __ ] see
yeah no i agree with that i've never
talked about i never hear any because if
you talk about deep [ __ ] conviction
you're an egomaniac if you talk about
humility it's like
people like gary you can't be kind you
get walked all over and take advantage
of them like
no you don't i never get taken advantage
of you're using you're manipulating
people and using that as a fake move or
like that's not true kindness is a
strength
yeah i agree i i don't i don't think you
can do great stuff
if you don't recognize quickly when
you're wrong you can't change your
opinion like that
and you know i have the same view like
there's certain things i'm wildly
confident in my ability to do
i'm also very capable of admitting i'm
wrong within seconds and changing my
course immediately
i do it all the time all the time
important success in life attribute to
success in life
zubin says we haven't let you talk a
whole lot like on that because you've
gotten very under the hood with me
and don't [ __ ] make me feel good i
just know how i operate
as somebody who can co-sign to that has
that been surprising to you with
somebody that has as much conviction
of like me changing minds in meetings
i think one one thing uh about you
that's that's uh
quite interesting as you mentioned is
that you've got a conviction so we're
going to meeting sometimes and you're
set on what you think the right path is
right yeah i'll even tell you beforehand
i'm like we're going into this yeah
yeah but if presented the right
case and information etc you'll turn on
a dime
and that's what you're talking about
jason yeah i believe in that [ __ ]
i don't know about intellectual honesty
ability to
but that is humility and conviction and
self-awareness and understanding so that
you're actually because what's the
intention
both of you have intentions to do good
move things forward
and so you rely on your conviction to be
able to do that but you don't
heavily rely on it where it becomes a
fault
because i play in a game of merit
ultimately it's going to play out and
everyone's going to see the score
so why be delusional all the way through
i'm not tricking people like it's one of
their
facts matter like your decision was
wrong you have to then own it you can't
like
i'm not going to be a revisionist in
history
i know this shows about jason but just
one more thing about you gary
it's because you want to win you don't
want to be right correct
and i and i want to win in a way that
feels nice for yeah
associated with it i want to win on a
team i'm not a golfer or a boxer
i'm that's why i like football 53
[ __ ]
i love team i love that feeling i might
want to be a captain
they said when you hear that back to
squash tennis
resonate like yeah definitely yeah i
mean i
a lot of my successes has come from who
i've hired and and who's been part of my
team
and i've never had an ego about um it
has to be the me show
you know i've always looked for who are
people that complement my strengths
and help my weaknesses um and i've
deliberately assembled teams around me
to you know with specifically i've
always had a few people on my team who
tell me no
who tell me the emperor's wearing no
clothes and who called [ __ ]
and i said last thing because i bounce
because you i like bantering with you
and we may have to do this again on my
podcast because i
i see something here where we can get
because we're here we are again
how many times in your career have you
seen somebody who figured out in
different places not in your cocoon
that being the person that calls
[ __ ] has some political clout
and they actually call [ __ ] when
they don't fully believe it and they
don't realize that you get it
and that they're act like there's the
people that you just talked about that
you value tremendously
have you come across because i'm trying
to help people that are listening that
maybe are early in their process
have you come across the individuals who
think that's like a smart move
but then when poked and prodded
naysayer that sees that they're around a
leader that
has a lot of juice and is often correct
so they try to sneak in and think that's
a move
but in reality it ultimately exposes
them thoughts on that
yeah for sure i mean i i it typically is
the insecure folks because they want to
they want to appear like they're adding
value and by
by being a naysayer it appears that
they're being thoughtful and adding
value
um when sometimes it's actually just not
necessary
or ultimately they get exposed to being
uncomfortably wrong
right right right right i'm out of here
i've been a mess i enjoyed this too much
jason
happy new year i'll talk to you guys
soon bye
okay let's shift gears a little bit that
was fantastic um
everybody got a good sense of look the
reality is we want people to
gain from this and there are all sorts
of ways that people are going to gain
from the show when you're talking about
an e-commerce business or direct to
consumer it's not just about
how to sell products online it's about
how to live healthy
how to have a life that is rewarding
um where you're giving back and then
ultimately where you have peace of mind
um
and you're able to do things that that
are meaningful let's
go back to where we were a couple of
minutes ago
around hue and let's go from hew to
human code to where you are today
sure sure so um
when when hugh started to take off
um uh you know and i was i i've always
been the chairman
um you know my my wife and my
brother-in-law
uh were in the day-to-day operations um
when when you started to take off you
know i think we realized collectively
that
we needed to you know really spend more
time on the strategy and the focus of it
and around that time i was deriving so
much enjoyment
from just the feedback we were getting
from people like
you know we i mean we got all sorts of
great messages from people who were
diabetic
or who had autoimmune or who didn't
think they could eat you know
delicious things anymore and and i
remember thinking like
that was so much more satisfying and
rewarding than like generating big
returns
um which which you know that's what i
had done for the last
15 years and i started becoming an angel
investor in the early
uh you know called 2012 1314 time frame
um in in a lot of companies that had
similar ethos or philosophy or mission
of hue
um and in some cases i was advising
entrepreneurs and in other cases
you know i was helping uh and providing
capital
and i just realized that that you know
that was an area where i had just such a
good time
i felt like i had real um comparative
advantages
uh and i felt like it was actually you
know doing something for
for the planning and for people that was
near and dear to my heart
and um as that continued and and
we had a lot of success with you um
which has become quite a big company now
and we had a lot of success or i had a
lot of success with many of my uh angel
investments um
and i just realized that i was sort of
done with the hedge fund thing after 20
years
i had a great run um you know my last
couple years
uh were were not great but the first 15
16 years were
and i sort of you know i wondered
whether that was a function of
the markets changing on me or just some
internal
compass telling me like you're done with
this chapter it's been 20 years jason
and um and i i realized i wanted to
build a company
you know so humanco is actually the
the culmination of all this experience
where
i wanted to build a company that was not
a fund
it's a holding company um it was really
modeled after a hybrid of
you know i'll call it berkshire hathaway
and procter gamble
or mondelez um you know mondelez
actually bought a minority stake in hugh
a couple years ago
and is now one of our partners um and
i wanted to build a next generation uh
company
that um that espoused
and and and really stood for all the
principles that
that we've been thinking about and i've
been thinking about for the last decade
and using the success of both my finance
career as well as my
investing in um consumer products
and as well as my uh direct experience
in in co-founding
uh and helping lead uh hugh over the
last decade
um we we felt like that there wasn't
really anything out there that was like
that
um and human co was really just
uh the culmination of all this we are
now
taking what uh what my family and i did
with hugh
um and we're doing that with other
verticals
uh that aren't snacking you know hugh is
a is a clean snacking company
but i feel like in anything that's a
consumer product or a consumable
there's a tremendous need still for
helping people live healthier lives and
i think that there's a lot of categories
for anything you put in your body
or on your body where either
the product isn't that healthy and it's
still harming humanity
uh or it's harming the earth or um
it just doesn't work very well and and i
think that
it's odd to me but there's just not a
lot of stuff out there that's both epic
and clean at the same time and so we
created human code to do just that as a
singular company
with the spirit of eventually taking it
public it's fantastic
um jason so for the audience you
obviously went through a series of
events as you mentioned
um a number of uh issues from an
autoimmune standpoint um that hit you in
an acute manner
and it caused you to have to change your
behavior
and that gave you meaning and gave you
purpose in terms of what you're doing
now and and to your earlier point i mean
you alluded to it it's like
they're people who have certain issues
that they need to eat
and healthy in order to suppress those
challenges
and then there are other people who can
actually get much
better performance and i'm not talking
about performances in like your running
or you're working out or whatever
but even mental performance and mental
calm and eq
acuity again you went through something
that gave you that
uh that north star and that purpose
for those that are listening how can
they find that for themselves how can
they find
meaningful purpose without going through
adversity
yeah no that's a great question i you
know i think
i've been through a lot of introspection
over the decades and
um you know i i don't think
i i don't think i've ever quite found
exactly what my quote calling was
um but i certainly know what my callings
were not
um and for me what i what i tried to pay
attention to
is what are the things that you end up
gravitating towards in your free time
what are the things that you just end up
finding you know kind of gives you that
little light
in your brain when you see it and it
gives you sort of an excitement
you know for some people it's sports for
some people it's music for some people
it's movies
for some people it's reading a good book
for some people it's a great
conversation
with someone interesting um you know
this idea of
flow you know that that that's been
sort of talked about now for the last 30
40 years um
is is a measurable psychological state
um and and you have to be attuned to
what are the things
that that really bring you joy and one
of the things that
you can't quite put your finger on it
but you're like i don't really like this
i would never do this in my free time
and for me it was just about paying
attention to all those little cues
over a very long period of time and for
me when i would get stressed or i would
be in places
that i think my body didn't want me to
be
it would manifest physiologically as
illness and and i'm kind of like a
canary in the coal mine where
everyone has this problem you know it is
well
understood that a lot of psychological
issues
manifest uh physiologically sure um
and make you sick or make you you know
develop
ailments um and and i think a lot of
people just aren't attuned
to the cues that you get daily and
weekly
about like why is this bothering you and
why is it not
absolutely i mean that's you talk about
um
i think it's it's a sensitivity some
people um
it shows up physiologically and in many
ways
it's a blessing because if you're able
to
physiologically respond to something
you're more aware of it
then subconsciously some places you go
make you happy some sense make you happy
some things make you sad whatever
we're just not attuned to those on a
general on a regular basis but i think
that
those things truly impact i think gary
um
i think gary said it best it's like
you're focused on what people are
putting in their body
what they're putting on their body
gary's focused on what they're
putting here and they're also and then
who you have around you and whatnot i
mean they're all these facets
that make you happy make you feel
fulfilled as an individual
again folks of the show's commerce
obviously but i think
it's important for us to think about
these things and as i've mentioned many
times on the show
especially for those folks that aren't
already in market that are like [ __ ] i
want to jump on this direct-to-consumer
um train if you're going to spend the
time and i
have conversations with people all the
time they reach out to me friends
cousins etc i want to sell something
online okay great what do you want to do
i'm thinking about this idea i'm like if
you're going to do
anything if you're going to start with a
blank canvas
start with something that you feel like
improves people's lives
and is positive for them why are you
going to do the same thing somebody else
is going to do
that doesn't actually benefit and i
realize this is relative we're talking
about things that
are relative conversations it's not a
good bad whatever but it's more a matter
of at least you feel like you're doing
something positive
so shifting again further into commerce
and then we want to take audience
questions so drop in your questions
please uh wherever you are
in the comments and we'll get to them um
so
direct to consumer retail uh
how does an organization like humanko
how does a brand like you
how do you see the role of retail direct
to consumer uh
e-tailers delivery service providers how
do you see these things
now that kind of the the the kovid spike
in e-commerce
has occurred we're several months past
that we're still
sustaining levels e-commerce isn't going
anywhere
consumers that have uh tried purchasing
products online
in many categories are going to stick to
purchasing online where do you see all
this going moving forward
well i think for the listeners if
they're interested in actually
developing commerce
you know i i think it's important and
this is something i learned
you know over my 21-year investment
career
in and you know i've invested in and
shorted
literally thousands of companies over 20
years and you learn a lot when you do
that
and i think the most important thing
with investing which is one of the most
competitive pursuits
on the planet because of how many
dollars are at stake and how easy it is
to sort of play with the stock market
is it the most important thing that that
i think about with e-commerce
is you first have to understand what
game you're playing and you have to
understand
how the game is different today than it
was five years ago
and you know it's gotten easier
for people in their dorm room to launch
a product with shopify
and start selling it like in a week
um it's gotten easier to do that than
ever
in in our history and and that means
that there is a
proliferation and i'm sure you see it on
your social feeds there's a
proliferation of
tons and tons and tons of [ __ ] and
products and
this this this and this that so you
first have to know like
i'm entering a game that is insanely
competitive
just like when i went into the stock
market 21 years ago
i recognized even then it was insanely
competitive and today it's way more
competitive
and so then you have to ask what am i
doing that's different
and what am i providing that is unique
and why
is somebody going to want my thing over
the thousands of other things that are
just like it
and and and i think you have to be
humble about that because
there are so many choices um and there
are so many options
and you know for me um you know and by
the way i went into chocolate
with my brother-in-law and my wife 10
years ago
without thinking about it as like a true
business because had i walked through
the whole foods aisles
or any grocery store and you literally
see a hundred brands of chocolate
my investment mind would have flashed
like red flag red flag like don't do it
um and so i think contextualizing
what it is that you're doing differently
um is probably the first
important step i think as a consumer and
i always try to look at things as an
investor and a consumer
as a consumer i am overwhelmed with the
options i see online
i'm overwhelmed with how many different
like
like clean cookware options there are
and i'm overwhelmed with how many keto
cookies there are
and i'm overwhelmed with how many like
you know keto bars and
protein powders and you know liquid iv
copycats and
and um and i don't even know where to
start
and so i think the first question is
how do you shine amidst the noise
yep and what are you going to do to
shine and i
i think personally i think the pendulum
has swung
where five six years ago if you or when
we did this eight nine ten years ago
this was highly unique nobody was doing
clean chocolate
and certainly nobody was doing clean
chocolate that tasted good
yup um and what i think my family and i
did well
with that which was mostly intentional
but a lot of it was luck
was we said you know what we're not
going to play the venture capital game
of just grow revenue at any price
flatter it everywhere you know press try
to generate revenue and then hope
somebody pays us a multiple revenue
we wanted to build true brand equity i
think there is a lack today
of true brand equity for a lot of
companies
and the reason i think that is because
we have evolved
in terms of e-commerce so much towards
what you can measure is what you need to
bet on
so cac ltv roads
these are all measurable things so let's
just spend all of our time on that
which you know five years ago was the
genius move
but today everyone's so myopically
focused on just those variables
that what i fear with a lot of these
brands is when they turn off their
marketing spigot
and the customer has a hundred other
choices
of keto cookie to choose from they're
not gonna remember your brand
and they only used your brand because
you kept bombarding them with ads
and so i think what worked for the
previous 100 years of consumer products
prior to call it 10 years ago is
probably right
which is that you need to build real
brand equity
and building real brand equity takes
time it takes authenticity
it's slower um but at the end of the day
you know when you stop advertising as
much as you think you need to
you want people to remember like oh i
love that brand and i know what that
brand stands for
and i know the people behind that brand
and when [ __ ] hits the fan
and i sort of remember like what kept me
comfort during covid
there are a lot of people who are going
to say i was baking healthy items with
hugh gems
and they'll remember that in 20 years
and like
that's not because we blasted them with
high roast ads
because we have a real authentic mission
behind what we're doing
and i think that this cohort that's on
this call
needs to really think about what is it
going to take to build a lasting brand
brilliant and i think that one of the
things that we need to think about and
you touched on it
but the meaning and the authenticity
behind what you're doing
is ultimately the brand that you're
building and turning that spigot off is
a great way of putting it because so
many brands
uh they survive on advertising
you turn that off nobody knows who they
are and and
the the reality is because they don't
stand for something in the consumer
psyche
and it's not a matter of just pounding
them with messaging but things that are
meaningful things that
make them think things that are
provocative and things that they can get
behind i think that
again to your point even five years ago
was a lot easier because there weren't
as many brands advertising on facebook
instagram etc so they're going straight
after row apps
now that's become difficult as well
because you can't actually just go there
and say i'm just going to start selling
products and making money
unless your objective to your point is
just to inflate revenue
and exit but then you're not really
building a business and if you want to
build a sustainable business
you have to do something that will
be effective in the long run and isn't
just a matter of playing an arbitrage
game of
cac and rolaz um another question for
you jason and then we'll get to the
audience
um you talk about
early on and i think this is a really
interesting
thing i want to discuss here early on
you didn't walk the aisles of whole
foods
to see what the competitive set was what
their ingredients were
what their branding was how you were
going to do it differently so on and so
forth
while in your day job as a hedge fund
you were assessing these things
daily right but when it came to your
passion project
you did what you thought was right but
now
you're looking at uh companies all the
time for
human co you're launching new brands etc
so
what is it from back then that you still
do today
and now having been in the game long
enough and being as successful as you
are in it
what is it that you do now when you
think about a new category or you're
thinking about a new product
either for acquisition or to develop a
new product how do you actually
um effectively assess what's out there
and not let it dissuade you from getting
into it well just to be clear
i did actually know the competitive set
when we
created our chocolate we but we created
our chocolate more as a passion
sure and and what i was saying is if i
was creating that chocolate with my
brother-in-law
just to make money and just as an
investment we would never have done it
got it we did it because we felt there
was a need
and that most of the healthy chocolate
out there sucked and
and that most of the chocolate that
tasted good had a lot of crap in it yup
um so it wasn't you know i was trying to
get more at
you know when you approach a problem it
can't just be about the money
um you know because you'll end up never
having enough
energy to pursue it and continue with it
because ultimately i have infinite
energy in things that i naturally just
love doing
i don't have to think about like
motivating like it's just how i am
and if you try to do things just for
money
you will always lose because that
intrinsic motivation isn't there
um and eventually when you make enough
money it stops
um so what what we look for
um is in terms of like very specific
um we look for categories um
where it's a big market um
where the incumbents or the or the kind
of market leaders
are still uh pretty gross we use the
word gross
um and uh and we look for
areas where we think um we won't have a
lot of what i call performance
degradation
uh with a cleaner label and i'll give
you an example
so there's a reason you don't see many
super healthy clean bug sprays
you don't see them because they don't
work and so those have
severe performance uh degradation
when you try to use really healthy stuff
that
isn't sort of chemically or or slightly
toxic
um they just don't work because
ultimately you know you're killing bugs
or you're trying to deter them at a
minimum
and so we spent a lot of time on healthy
bug sprays
and we ultimately passed because we
didn't feel like we could do it
with the quality of ingredients that are
up to the human co standard
and then it also be effective chocolate
by contrast which was sort of my
first foray into this you know with with
uh with my family
um if you taste you chocolate
you'll notice that that's as good as any
chocolate you've ever had
for dark chocolate and we have literally
thousands
of people who say it's the best
chocolate they've ever had and
irrespective of whether it's healthy or
not
um and so that's an example of something
without performance degradation
if you try we just bought control of a
company called coconut bliss for humaco
it's a plant-based 100 organic
sustainable focused ice cream
um most plant-based ice creams that i
have come across
you know you're not eating ice cream and
it's very obvious
coconut bliss which we're going to
continue to improve
and and and slightly reformulate and
come out with new flavors
but coconut bliss was always one of my
favorites because it doesn't feel like
you're sacrificing
and it's organic and it's plant-based
and it's sustainable
um and and so we look for areas where we
think you can accomplish something
without degradation
we also want to focus on areas and this
is controversial
um but it's just an investment view for
us we also want to focus on areas where
there's
a what we call a high replenishment rate
um
there's certain products that have high
loyalty think of like toothpaste
um but have low replenishment rate um
where
at least for me i don't know for other
people but a tuba toothpaste lasts me
like over a month maybe two months so
i'm only interacting with that brand
five six times a year yeah um and and
that's not uh that's not a lot
whereas you know in things like coconut
bliss or huge chocolate
or or some of the other uh brands that
we're working on right now
there's much more interaction uh with
the products
um and and for us again this is a
preference but for us that was that's an
important attribute
um i you know and this is sort of ironic
um most of the things that i focused on
have not been particularly dtc or ecom
friendly
um and that's partially by design but
it's partially just because i gravitated
towards things that are refrigerated or
frozen
um and you know in an odd way
you know i think things that are harder
to do
are less competitive because by
definition they're harder to do
um so those are just sort of a sampling
of of kind of the things that we look
for
that's fantastic and i think that the uh
the point about replenishment
isn't a controversial one it's a
business one right i mean it's
and for those that are listening they
they hear all the time about
um things like uh subscription and
whatnot and it's not just a matter of
what is a subscription model but how
often is this product can get
replenished and then what category
is it in um where there's brand affinity
and they're gonna stick with you
all right so this has been a fantastic
conversation let's jump to a few
questions
um dustin do your thing so this first
one comes in from xx
daisy xx a jason h car
what are some management advice you can
give me i work at a dairy queen as a
manager and i want my team to feel the
same way about work like i do
i want to be the best leader great
question
oh it's great um you know
this one's this one's an interesting one
daisy because i've done i've done some
jobs
that you know there's certain types of
jobs that are more naturally fulfilling
than others um and and i've definitely
done some jobs over the years that are
not naturally fulfilling
and i think um you know when you're a
manager
there's elements of being a manager that
are fulfilling because you're training
people you're leading people you're
seeing progress
but if they're below you and they're not
managing people they have to find
fulfillment and purpose and what i've
learned is that fulfillment and purpose
are necessary for anyone to have
enjoyment
in whatever they do and money does not
accomplish fulfillment and purpose
and so it could be just finding small
tasks
finding small things in their daily
habits
that they can take satisfaction
and that they can see progress in humans
need to see progress
they need to see fulfillment and they
need to see purpose
and if those are all missing you can't
be really happy and your morale will be
terrible
so i would suggest you find in what they
do
and some people gamify you know menial
tasks sometimes
you know like checking the cash register
or filling out forms or
cleaning the bathroom um you know
there's all sorts of things that you can
do
where you could provide pride and
fulfillment
for doing a job well done and i think
you as a manager have to think about
what it is
that if you interview each one of them
and you ask them what is it in your day
that you actually like doing and tell me
a time when you were happy
and then taking that information and
then optimizing on that
so that you can you know whatever task
they're doing
you can try to make it more
purpose-driven
absolutely there's a reason why uh they
say
how you do one thing is how you do
everything and for people
when that rings true to you and you
realize that
the effort that you put into one thing
is how you basically what output you get
and how you feel about yourself
is gonna be about everything else you do
to jason's point finding those little
wins and seeing how it makes you feel
about yourself that positive
reinforcement should continue
um next question comes in i'm starting a
seafood delivery business
fresh live sustainable traceable seafood
from the canadian east coast
the mountains and banff and canmore etc
we'll be doing
b to b but heavily on b to c so
presumably the question here even though
it's not a question congratulations to
you is the answer to that
um but the question here then you talk
about frozen foods
let's talk about seafood for a moment
what are your thoughts around the entire
seafood sector
or frozen uh food uh
so i love frozen food as a category i
think you know i'm i'm
very much against uh preservatives
and chemicals to prolong shelf life
you know frozen is the oldest and best
technology that we have
still to this day for preserving food um
and and it's also the cleanest and the
safest safest that's what i was gonna
say and it also
maintains the highest density of
nutrients so i'm a huge fan of frozen
um i love seafood seafood
you know in most periods non-covet is
the bulk of the meat
animal products i tend to eat um
and i'm a huge proponent and supporter
of wild seafood
um there's a great company uh i believe
it's based in canada called vital choice
that i've been a customer of for
probably 15 years um
and my family buys a lot of wild alaskan
uh salmon um and uh a lot of
other wild fish so i you know i love it
i think the challenge for most people
with
with wild or sustainably raised seafood
is it's expensive
and i think convincing people uh
as to the merits of why it should be
expensive
is a challenge um but people need to
realize that catching a fish
with a pole uh and then shipping it
and so that it's preserved is not a
cheap endeavor yep um so i'm a huge fan
of of
of that fantastic chef lizette
asks us should you cut off the marketing
well at some point just to test and
measure your brand worth so
i love that so when we've looked at
companies to invest in
and i see a very high
um kind of dtc success rate
and i see a high spend um
you know one of the things which i've
not been able to accomplish by the way
but one of the things that
i've always wanted to do as part of the
due diligence is force them to shut off
the spending for a month and see what
happens um
i think if you have control of that and
you're not worried about what happens
and you don't have shareholders that you
have to explain that to
i think it's a fabulous exercise um
because you know there's there's
there's only there's only so many ways
to measure it um
and that that is a true way to measure
do people remember your brand when you
stop telling them about it
yeah and i think the there are other
kind of micro
ways of doing that it's not going to
have as mass uh massive amount of impact
is what jason's talking about here
towards just
shutting it off but the other way of
doing that is just to understand how
what percentage of your sales are
referral sales so someone's actually
introduced them so non-attributable to
advertising i know attribution is a
whole
situation to get in that right now we
don't have the time to but
non-attributable
uh ways are people sharing it with their
friends etc
and is that how people are coming in um
jason we've taken quite a bit of your
time today let's have one more question
if that's okay and then to gary's point
we got to get you on uh for a long extra
time
so um next question next question
so while uh dustin's pulling it up
what's your opinion of retirement with
the except expansion of the gig economy
and then we have one more question after
this okay um
so i i i think i know what this question
is getting at
um i i don't think i'm ever gonna
you know conventionally retire um and
but i'll i'll definitely continue to
change you know
the phases of my life and and how
involved i am in various things and and
you know thinking about kind of my own
energy levels as i age
um you know but there's a lot of
literature on people
truly retiring you know particularly
people who are in sort of
you know public service where they get a
pension and they actually have to retire
policemen firemen those types and
there's a very high incidence of
depression
and a very high incidence of just like
mental malaise because again getting to
my earlier
point um on purpose and fulfillment
people need purpose and they need to
have things
that they're always working towards even
if it's not a huge proportion of their
day
um you know my father who technically
retired
six seven years ago he volunteers
at a hospital um and and works mostly
with people who are dying
um because he just likes interacting
with them and he likes
he likes providing sort of a friendly
face and being able to talk to them
um he doesn't get paid for it but it
provides him fulfillment
and so i i think retirement is sort of
the death of your mind
and i would say that you could
definitely like i technically retired
from the hedge fund industry
but i'm not retired um you know i was
done with that chapter
i spent you know every ounce of energy i
had on that chapter
and now i wanted to focus on something
else so i would say
i don't think retirement is is a healthy
thing to do
i think always having a focus in an area
that brings you fulfillment
even if it means no money so you could
financially retire but i always think
you should be mentally engaged
and put it differently correct me if i'm
wrong but i think
it's interesting concept you're bringing
up which is
taking retirement and breaking it up and
not thinking about retirement as a whole
but rather you might be financially fine
to retire or you might be fined from
another aspect
but to continue giving continue to use
your brain and continue
okay final question julian er bill
asks what are your opinions on live
stream experiential ecommerce
uh let me share mine jason and then i'd
love to have your opinion on this
i've never experienced this so i'm
curiou i don't even know if i can answer
it
and and let's hope i can answer it as
well so here's the way i see this
retail for however many years
everybody's been saying retail needs to
be more like digital we got to get
retail
more like online but the reality is
there's a lot of ways that the online
experience can be
more like retail so when you're asking
this question what comes to mind
immediately for me
are the smart and uh savvy
brands that had retail employees that
were able to
when retail was closed take those retail
employees make them available
as online stylists online advisors etc
that somebody could book for 15 to 30
minutes
and interact with online on the site so
taking that real world experience and
bringing it to the site
so that i'm shopping for example fashion
site
and i want to figure out what to do or a
beauty site etc that brand had a bunch
of people in retail that if you had gone
into a nordstrom macy's etc they would
have talked to you
now take those people make them
accessible online so that i can book
them for 15 minutes and they can help me
with makeup tips
to me is one way of answering yeah look
i
i i think there is a great need even
though i haven't experienced this per se
yeah i am a big fan of experiential
marketing
i am a big fan of of
experiences that involve more of your
senses
and engage you more as a person because
those are more memorable
um and and i do think that there are
especially with covet and and the rise
of
of
all of this digital activity i think
there's a lot of things that are still
lacking
um you know whether it's interaction
with a salesperson
whether it's being able to sort of see
what stuff looks like
on you and i know that you know uh
augmented reality is trying to do some
of that where you could sort of try
stuff on
um but i think there's elements of
shopping that will never be able to be
truly replicated
through digital but i do think we need
to think about
more and more ways to make it feel fun
and interactive
even like you know browsing for books
and i'm a huge
uh book fan and i love to read but like
even now like 20 years in from you know
when amazon first started selling books
online or 25 years
um like i still like going into a book
shop
and looking at you know the whole row
and sort of pulling it out and flipping
through it um
and i find that very pleasurable uh
relative to like
scrolling on an amazon feed so i i think
it's a i think it's definitely the
future
i haven't experienced what you're
talking about but the idea definitely
resonates with me
yeah absolutely and and to your energy
here i think the the the reality is
there it is and there always be will be
a place for physical retail
it's just a matter of retail giving
consumers
value and not just existing because
that's the only place people can go buy
something
that's right curation and value and
experience for sure
absolutely jason it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for joining
us today
thank you for your time and uh i'll talk
to you soon
absolutely and i'm sure the audience got
a lot uh i know there are a lot ton of
questions we didn't get to so please
tweet at us
uh at jason at meet gary and we'll get
to as soon as we can thanks so much
thank you for having me guys thank you
see ya